jetzt sieht es tatsächlich fest wir
menschen sind in der lage gezielt in die
evolution einzugreifen kaputte gene raus
aus dem körper gesunde gene rein und
schon ist die erbkrankheit bewegt oder
viel schlimmer wir bauen uns den super
menschen mit einer einfachen und
effektiven technik unvorstellbar doch
genau das ist jetzt ein us
wissenschaftlerteam an menschlichen
embryonen gelungen was für die einen die
erfolgsmeldung überhaupt ist ist für die
anderen einfach nur unverantwortlich
auch man erbkrankheiten jetzt teilen
kann und ob es schon bald designerbabys
geben wird jetzt in science fiction
herzlich willkommen
die idee für designer babys die schon
länger doch bislang gibt es nicht nur
ethische bedenken wissenschaftler und
wissenschaftlerinnen waren bisher der
meinung dass die forschung noch nicht
weit genug sei die technik noch nicht
genügend ausgereift und zu
fehleranfällig dafür um sie tatsächlich
an menschen auszuprobieren
wir haben ja hier über die probleme
berichtet doch jetzt ist die idee der
designer babys prast realität geworden
es fehlt eigentlich nur noch ein kleiner
schritt bei dem experiment der
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
aus portman ging es konkret um die
lebensgefährliche herzmuskelschwäche
hypertrophe kardiomyopathie bei der der
herzmuskel an einer weise so sie kann
wächst dass er nicht mehr in der lage
ist das blut effizient in den
blutkreislauf zu pumpen und die
erbkrankheit ist gar nicht so selten
einer von 500 menschen ist getroffen und
in etwa 40 prozent ist das gnm y b p3
auf chromosom 11 notiert und somit klar
als ursachen zu benehmen wenn ein
elternteil diese mutation im erbgut
bewegt liegt das risiko dass die kinder
auch mit der besagten herzmuskelschwäche
geboren werden bei 50 prozent bei ihrem
experiment nutzen die forscherinnen und
forscher die sogenannte griff bacav 19
manchmal auch als das neue als werkzeug
der gentechnik benannt mit dieser
methode lassen sich ausgewählte gene
einfügen ausschalten oder auch
umschreiben und zwar sehr einfach
funktioniert ganz simpel wie eine schere
mit ihr kann die dna das erbgut ziemlich
effektiv verändert werden
das forscherteam aus portman befruchtete
in ihrem versuch gesunde eizellen von
menschen mit spermien eines bänder sehr
an eben dieser beschriebenen
herzmuskelschwäche liegt doch die
spritze nicht nur die spermien soll man
eben auch entsprechende griff beim
portier in die einzel
diese sollten den kaputten abschnitt der
die erbkrankheit auslöst ausschneiden
und durch einen gesunden abschnitt
ersetzen und tatsächlich in 42 von 58
millionen war der defekt behoben die
herzmuskelschwäche hatte sich also durch
den einsatz der körper methode nicht
mehr auf die hälfte
und übertragen sondern nur noch auf
knapp ein drittel ein ergebnis das viele
in der wissenschaftswelt den atem
anhalten lässt doch der versuch hat auch
schwächen die zahl der versuchs embryo
ist eher klein das ergebnis deswegen
nicht unbedingt aussagekräftig zudem ist
etwas seltsames passiert und das können
die forscherinnen und forscher einfach
nicht erklären
nicht der künstliche dna schnipsel der
christa proteine wo wir in die embryos
eingebaut sondern der gesunde schnitzel
aus der natürlichen eizelle der
eigentlich als kopiervorlage zur
reparatur dient zugespitzt formuliert
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler wissen nicht was sie da
getan haben offen bleibt zudem ob die
technik auch einsetzbar wäre wenn der
gendefekt sowohl väterlicher weit als
auch mütterlicherseits existieren würde
dennoch ist das ergebnis von großer
bedeutung bisher wurden erst drei
vergleichbare studien veröffentlicht ein
ähnlicher versuch chinesischer
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
musste frühzeitig abgebrochen werden es
gab zu viele ungeplante gehen
veränderungen die ungeahnte konsequenzen
mit sich hätten bringen können den tod
der embryos fehlbildung krebs oder
andere erkrankung wenn das ist das
riesige problem von chris zu viel geht
im wahrsten sinne des wortes dann eben
zu viel wird auch an anderen stellen des
erbgutes verändert und das zum teil
ziemlich unkontrolliert wie wir ja
berichtet haben dennoch ist das ergebnis
und auch der gesamte forschungszweig von
großer bedeutung denn bislang sind mehr
als 10.000 erbkrankheiten bekannt bei
denen ein elternteil defekte gene an
ihre kinder weitergeben und nur die
wenigsten dieser krankheiten will zu
behandeln oder gar zu heilen frauen mit
kinderwunsch könnten zudem auf eine
weitere hormonbehandlung verzichten da
sich durch diese methode die zahl der
brauchbaren also brauchbaren embryonen
nach einer künstlichen befruchtung
deutlich steigern ließe der versuch des
us forscherteam zeigt jedenfalls dass
gentechnisch modifizierte kinder keine
zukunftsmusik mehr sind sondern
wahrscheinlich nur noch eine frage der
zeit
zeit in der es kaum gehen wird das
risiko für nebenwirkungen so weit zu
senken
es ist irgendwann tatsächlich einfach
mal ein experimentierfreudiger forscher
ausprobieren aber keine angenehme
vorstellung völlig unbeeindruckt davon
was gesundheitsbehörden und
ethikkommissionen für angemessen halten
und wie weit die diskussion darüber
fortgeschritten ist ob es erlaubt sein
sollte erbgut vor der geburt so zu
bearbeiten wie sich mediziner oder
eltern wünschen dabei ist es noch mehr
als unklar was sollte ein
unwiderruflicher eingriff in das
menschliche erbgut und damit auch wenn
die evolution für konsequenzen haben
könnte langfristigen nebenwirkungen die
vielleicht erst unsere enkel bemerken
und auch ganz absurde dinge wären
möglich wenn wir wirklich das erbgut
verändern könnte es könnten super
menschen als soldaten gezüchtet werden
und das auch noch super einfach das ist
schon eine gespenstische perspektive und
wenn man sich da so manches totalitäre
regime vorstellt ist es nicht völlig
unwahrscheinlich
das wird auch getan wird wenn es möglich
ist über xing hat ihr euch natürlich auf
dem laufenden was das thema angeht wenn
ihr kein video dazu und auch zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollt dann wird
mir hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesst
nicht den auf die glocke hier geht es
weiter mit bakterien als datenspeicher
da geht es um die extremen möglichkeiten
begriff backert 9 bietet absolut irre
und gefährlich also nicht verpassen und
draufklicken und ansonsten besand bleibt
dran